I'm welcoming to the program today James
d'amour who's a former senior software
engineer at Google he was fired for
writing an internal document that
criticized the company's culture and
diversity practices so James you've
really been doing the interview rounds
lately and as as some of our mutual
Twitter followers have pointed out that
they've seen you mostly do interviews
with I guess what would fall under the
umbrella of right-wing media but as far
as I understand that's not because
that's what you've been seeking out
right right I've really been giving
interviews to most of the people that
have asked and it just happens that I
get very few long-form interview
requests from people they would identify
on the left why do you think that is
like in other words why has there been
this sort of what why do you believe
there's been more interest from the
right in interviewing you well I did
give several interviews to CNN and
Bloomberg Business Insider
and so I did give interviews to a lot
but I feel like they were very hostile
and the audience's reaction it was
actually they were on my side and so it
didn't look good for them when I gave
interviews that that maybe one and I
think they're just not willing to really
engage me in any long court discussion
because what I'm saying doesn't fit
their narrative that's interesting so
and so one of the things you're saying
is it's possible that the left has not
been interested in interviewing you
because it hasn't gone well for them
yeah that's at least one theory that I
asked that's interesting and in what way
has it been reflected that it didn't go
well I mean certainly I think if you
asked for example CNN about it and you
said hey a lot of the people a lot of
the audience sided with James d'amour I
would be shocked if they said yeah we
can't have that that's not good for us
if people side with James so in what way
do you think it was reflected that it
didn't go well for them well it just
seems like they're not fair maybe I just
based on the comments a lot of people
would dislike their videos and point out
how they just didn't like how they
treated me interesting well let's get
into
I've reviewed the the memo you wrote
again this morning in preparation for
our interview and you'd there's been
very general sort of assessments made of
this memo that was the start of you
ultimately being fired by Google there
are those who describe it as a sort of
evidence-based document about gender
differences others say that you're
perpetuating gender stereotypes what
would you say is sort of like the
primary thesis of your document about
Google's diversity policy so I think a
lot of our culture is really intolerant
to ideas that don't fit their ideology
and I was trying to present the ideas
that really go against some of the less
biases and use that data to try to help
us increase diversity so look at the
ways in which psychology has shown that
men and women differ on average and
perhaps make our culture and our working
environment more appropriate for some
women and what would be an example of
how workplace a workplace and if you
want to make it specific about your
former employer Google and even as your
department within Google I'm sort of
fine with that that might be interesting
what might be a change you'd suggest to
make the environment more appropriate
for women as you described yes sir if we
just look at some of the average
differences women being more cooperative
and sometimes less assertive we can
really try to promote people that are
cooperative and so those that help on
multiple different projects without
being the team lead for a particular
project because in our performance
reviews it's really looked positively if
you're the team lead and it's it's hard
to judge or if you're someone that only
helps on the project and also you know
we can restructure our team meetings to
really make it so it's not just the most
assertive person talking the entire time
that's interesting and so it is and to
be makes you make sure I'm understanding
what your
would it be are there specific gender
differences you've identified that would
make women sub-optimal to be team
leaders in the way in which they would
be expected to be at Google I think
maybe yes there are some expectations
that are put on Team lades that we
expect them to be more masculine in some
ways and that may not be relevant to
their actual work performance and so
that we should probably change and in
your estimation in the research you've
done do you believe that that difference
between men and women in that particular
sense you know you mentioned this
assertiveness thing you also talked
about women being more prone to anxiety
in the document that you wrote do you
believe that those differences are
biological or sort of cultural nature or
nurture as the phrase often goes yeah I
think there's a combination of both and
it really they combined and it's really
hard to disentangle one from the other
but you know there are reasons to
believe that there are biological roots
to a lot of these for example women with
prenatal high prenatal testosterone has
many masculine traits and even within
the world different cultures have
different gender gaps in this but it's
that the societies that treat men and
women more similarly those had the
largest gaps so the more prosperous
countries seem to allow men and women to
act how they normally would or talk
about you know what do you even normally
would what would be the baseline for
normality in terms of gender behavior in
your mind yes so I may be normally is
not the right word but just if you need
to act a certain way to even survive
then then you may be doing that and so
my one example that's relevant to stem
is that even within the United States if
you look at the lowest socioeconomic
status
there's actually not really much of a
gender gap in stem but then when you go
to the higher economic says there's a
much larger gap so men it stays about
the same but women drop out and go into
Social Work a lot of times and so
there's sort of an economic necessity to
go into stem because it's high paying
when you're a lower socioeconomic status
but oh if you're a richer then you
really don't need to work in stem if you
don't want to and James you mentioned
that some of the gender differences
could be related to sort of like what
people need to do to survive in 2017 do
you think that it's a matter of survival
these gender differences like
assertiveness and anxiety in corporate
culture for example is can we really
point to survival as the necessitating
factor between those differences I'm not
necessarily survival but really what you
want in life and you know people
generally if they start out poor and
they generally do want to be richer
right yeah I mean I guess I guess that's
a very general statement yes if you if
you were poor you probably would rather
would rather not be poor you know I I'm
very interested in this topic and I
found that the reaction when Larry
Summers at Harvard had said something
about you know figuring out if there are
differences between men and women when
it comes to predisposition to math or it
was something I actually don't remember
exactly but I remember thinking that
some of the initial reaction was sort of
overblown because I do think it would be
really important in society to be able
to explore that like why wouldn't we
want to know if indeed there is
something biological that makes men or
women predisposed to excel or struggle
in certain areas but to take one of the
things you just said this idea that in
countries where men and women are
treated more similarly you see larger
gaps in some of these areas I did a
quite a bit of research over the last
week and what I found was that the more
egalitarian a society is the smaller the
gender differences become in terms of
performance in science
math so in other words when when one
example would be a Villanova University
psych department study called
cross-national patterns of gender
differences in mathematics what they
found that was when women were most
secure and affirmed that the difference
between their performance in math and
science and that of men almost goes away
completely and that seems to be at odds
with what you said no sir I'm not really
interested in the actual ability of men
and women it's more of the personality
and in those societies the personality
is what diverges the most and so a lot
of the reason why there's a gap in stem
is not that women are necessarily worse
in math or science you know women are
actually doing better than men in pretty
much every field in in schooling but
they just choose to go into different
fields at some point and you know one of
the largest reasons why there are fewer
women in these STEM fields is that yes
men and women have about the same
quantitative ability on average but
women tend to have higher verbal ability
and especially among high performers men
are much more likely to be only good at
math and quantitative things and not so
good at women are more likely to be well
balanced and if you're well-balanced and
you don't need to work in stem you can
work in law or other fields that require
verbal ability while the men really just
need to work in stem now that's very
interesting to me because correct me if
I'm wrong part of your criticism of the
Google diversity policy was that it was
trying to sort of impose some kind of
hiring equality 5050 equality between
men and women that might not correlate
with what you believe might be the best
fits but what the argument you just made
which is listen there are lots of men
who were only good at math they're not
so good as women at verbal skills so by
over hiring women in the departments
where being a good at math is sort of a
prerequisite
would be herding men's op opportunity to
be hired isn't that just the exact
policy you're against just meant to
disproportionately hire men in these
departments like it I'm hearing the
exact opposite of the policy you're
criticizing all right sorry I I don't
see how that's exactly the opposite I
I'm really just saying that if in a
world without any discrimination and
where we treat men and women exactly the
same we wouldn't expect fifty fifty
percent of women interested in working
in tech and that was largely the thesis
that I was trying to counter in the
document because that is something that
I heard over and over again at Google
that oh if only we were able to get rid
of all the sexism then we would have
5050 okay but my point was if you're
saying listen women are really good at
lots of other types of jobs by virtue of
having better verbal skills as you said
and there are lots of men who wouldn't
be good at those jobs therefore we
should be hiring more men when being
good at math is the sole prerequisite
isn't that the same type of sort of
direction of saying we need to hire more
men because they're not going to do as
well in other jobs but you're being
critical of the hiring of women for the
exact same reason I don't I'm not sure
if I'm expressing myself clearly but is
that does that make any sense I'm really
not saying that oh we should hire men
because of this I'm just saying we
shouldn't discriminate when we're hiring
and if our natural hiring like we
wouldn't expect women that are both good
at math and verbal to necessarily choose
down and we shouldn't uh like we sort of
infantile wise women in this way where
we say that we know what's best for you
and even though these women are choosing
to not go into stem we're sort of
guilting them because oh you you can
work in stem you know this is not just
men's work and but when they really just
prefer something else where
guilting them and what would be an
example of guilting women into going
into stem like and what way have women
been guilted into going into stem yeah
so I hear multiple anecdotes of people
that went into stem or coding simply to
show that women can do it and then they
end up dropping out later because if
they didn't go into it because they were
passionate about it they were just into
it because they were pushed into it but
I'm surprised to hear you as a you know
former senior engineer right at Google
to use a few anecdotes that you've heard
of to show that the guilting of women is
really the problem you describe it to be
like I know of one man who went into
nursing because he felt there aren't
enough male nurses because of the stigma
that women make better nurses but the
fact that I know that one guy doesn't
really tell me anything empirically does
it well yes but so we can go off of we
don't need to use anecdotes we can look
at the dropout rate of tech and it's
much higher for women and when you look
at the reason why it's often that they
simply want a different type of career
so there's differences in what type of
career men and women want and the field
the stem is often characterized as is
realistic and that's one that has a
large gender gap so realistic being you
know working with systems and things and
if you look at the women that drop out
the biggest predictor is whether or not
they want a career in realistic fields
okay let's personally James dam or
former senior software engineer at
Google we will take a break and continue
our conversation with him we're
continuing our conversation with James
d'amour who's a former senior software
engineer at Google he was fired for
writing an internal document that
criticized the company's culture and
diversity practices I want to talk a
little bit about that aspect if we can
James sort of the harming aspect of
Google's biases as you've described them
I was thinking you know the one of your
critiques was about the the programs and
mentoring and class
is for people of a certain gender or
race within Google I'm curious if you
believed that people of a certain gender
or race had maybe additional issues to
deal with right in addition to all of
the issues that any employee might be
presented with at a job wouldn't it be
okay for a company as large and well
resourced as Google to say hey in
addition to all of the resources that
are available to all employees if you
are dealing with an issue as a result of
gender or racial biases or whatever here
are some extra resources for you what's
wrong with that yet so I think this can
be my critique you must clearly be seen
in one of the programs that was only for
women so this program addressed the fact
that women are less assertive and
they're more cooperative and how they
could really act more masculine in the
workplace or leverage some of these
super men traits but there are men that
also had those traits and they really
don't have any support and so rather
than just having a program that's for
anyone that has these particular
personality traits we really stereotype
women and then and say only women can go
into this program but you said that a
lot of your analysis is based on the
averages of individual rights the
averages of women and the average of men
and if on average as you describe women
are much more likely to struggle with
these shortcomings as you have
identified them in the workplace isn't
it logical that these programs would be
tailored to them I mean again we're
talking about the average woman yes so
we can use the averages in population
level distributions to say whether or
not one population will be
disproportionately affected by something
sure but that doesn't mean that everyone
in that population has those traits and
no one else has those traits and that
was really the stereotyping that's
happening at Google that was trying to
counter yeah I mean I guess you know the
I I think what what you've written is
very very interesting because
both states many it makes many
assertions which I think intuitively
makes sense to many many people who have
been in the corporate world but at the
same time I feel like some of the
conclusions are where I'm sort of ending
up with question marks I mean for to
take one example you write in addition
to the assertiveness then you talk about
women are on average more anxious my
immediate question when I read that is
are women more anxious because they are
women though and if they're not then
you're basically ceding to society
whatever it is that makes women more
anxious as traditionally defined you
know this this anxiety gap is something
I'm sort of familiar with and most of
the research on that finds that women in
in male-dominated fields or departments
right such as maybe stem tech
engineering whatever that they do suffer
harsher penalties than men when they
make mistakes wouldn't that be a reason
why women might be more anxious that is
not necessarily linked to biology or
them being women yes I mean if we find
ways in which men and women are treated
differently in the workplace we should
definitely look into that and that's not
right
I the psychological studies that show
that women report higher levels anxiety
aren't just related to women in
male-dominated fields though it the
theories are sort of they've linked them
to our moan levels actually because oh
the anxiety gap is largest when women
are in their reproductive years and the
gap drops after menopause so there are
signs that there's some biological link
and it's not necessarily just that men
and women are treated differently yeah I
mean I think the truth is that every
single one of these issues you're
pointing out has it's and you said this
at the beginning in your defense that
there's sort of a mix right between
nature and nurture and for me and tell
me if you disagree James I think we
would probably find common ground on
this just about every issue you're
talking about if we can find a sort of
biological or hormonal
basis for it it is relevant insofar as
it might predispose someone in certain
situations to exhibit certain tendencies
or feelings or behaviors or actions have
everything I'm reading says that at this
point the sort of serious scholarship on
this is that there may be
predispositions which by virtue of one's
environments can either be activated or
not and activated to certain degrees but
I've really not read anything that
indicates that in a total vacuum
biological differences alone would
account for speaking only about the
differences you wrote about that we
could just point to biological
differences do you tend to agree with
that or do you think that there are
these differences explained only by
biology yeah I mean I agree that it just
predisposes you and that experience
really shapes you but I I was really
trying to counter the total social
constructionist viewpoint which is
prevalent at Google do you think that to
get now to the firing that took place as
a result of what you wrote do you think
that the firing that took place violated
labor law I'd rather not get into the
actual legal stuff because you know I'm
not an expert on the law but I think you
are you are an engineer who's doing
interviews about gender differences
right I mean do you consider yourself an
expert there I've read significantly
into this field and you know I was doing
a PhD at Harvard in biology so I mean I
have significantly more expertise on
this than most people both at Google
that we're doing the diversity programs
and people that are interviewing me okay
so I'm guessing you've done a lot of
research into the legality of what
happened I mean are you at least
exploring whether something illegal was
done yes we're exploring it and the
National Labor Relations Board is
investigating Google as we speak
are you happy with the way that this is
ultimately gone in other words if you
could go back and say undo the possible
legal claims undo being invited onto all
these programs to talk about my views on
gender differences mind being yours of
course undo the release of
this memo and just go back to your job
as a senior software engineer as Google
would you want that yeah I definitely
enjoy my work at Google and I see this
potentially you know causing an even
larger divide in our society which is
really something that I don't want i i i
really don't like regretting things in
general just because yeah that doesn't
really go it's not good for your
long-term health I don't think but yeah
I I'm hopeful that some good will come
from this though what what good could
come of it what would be a good thing
with the good thing relate to changes in
Google's diversity policy would it
relate to some kind of legal or
financial resolution for you as an
individual like what would be the golden
standard for what could come of this I
think really my main goal is empowering
people to be able to speak their opinion
and opening up topics for discussion
rather than silencing people as we're
currently doing and what other examples
do you have or are there other examples
from Google that you have of people
being silenced uh yeah there's largely
just ideas around the social progressive
politics those really can't be discussed
at all and you know for example if
someone goes out and says well they
voted for Trump then they'll immediately
be ostracized and they really can't
defend Trump in any way which you know
no one is 100% wrong on everything and
so you know there may be some things
that you can defend about Trump even
though you know I don't agree with him
on a lot of things so it's it's really
harmful to Google and society in general
if we just say no you can't talk about
anything like this but hold on a second
who is so let me see if I understand
you're saying that at Google there's a
progressive culture I think you
understood that part and that certainly
some people who work at Google voted for
Donald Trump I mean it's a huge company
there's no way it's going to be all non
Trump voters and you're saying that if
they state
they voted for Trump or it becomes known
that they voted for Trump then they're
not allowed to talk about it or they're
unable to defend Trump's actions I'm
just not sure I get what you're saying
they'll be ostracized they'll be
reported to HR for creating a hostile
work environment and they'll be put on
black lists where people will theirs
they have lists of people that are
basically conservatives or freethinkers
and they will try to get that person
fired they'll harass them at work and
then once they are fired
they'll blacklist them on other
companies so they won't be able to be
hired okay so when you say they have
black lists of conservatives are you
saying Google Human Resources maintains
a list of conservative politically
conservative employees no but many
managers and other people at Google do
so I wouldn't go so far and say that
Google has some official spreadsheet but
there are multiple people that have them
and they share them between them so so
you're saying individual managers at
Google who are progressive maintain
lists of employees they've identified as
politically conservative they share the
lists and then how are the lists used
all right so they make sure they try to
sabotage that person's work and they
make sure that that person isn't hired
in any other company or any other major
company at least and how can they do
that because as far as I know when
someone applies to work elsewhere and
they list a reference at least in
Massachusetts I don't know how it is in
California but I thought that this was
pretty widespread you're not really
allowed legally to give a sort of
negative review of the person's work
you're able to you know basically say
this person was employed by me they
worked for me within these dates etc but
you're not really allowed to say
anything negative so how is that being
communicated how can someone at Google
prevent an individual from being hired
elsewhere so someone that's involved in
hiring at that other company will likely
get hold of this list of people so
you're saying if you apply it I don't
know you apply it Deloitte I don't even
know what about you you apply it Netflix
Netflix hiring is a
where that google has a political
blacklist so if they see Google listed
on their applicants resume they will
contact someone at Google and say hey is
so-and-so on the conservative list yes I
don't actually know the mechanics of how
they do it because this is kind of crazy
all right when you actually think
through the mechanics yeah I mean it's a
crazy thing that they're doing my
they've admitted to doing it though so I
I don't know the exact specifics but
they've actually admitted to doing
basically this basically this okay all
right well I pledge to look into that in
more detail because that I'm super
interested if that's going on I want to
know about it and I want to explore it
more what's next for you James yeah I'm
not sure I I still looking for what's
best for me and you know what type of
work I really want to do because you
know you say I I mean I'm not super
passionate necessarily about coding I
was doing biology before this so I
really can do multiple different things
at this point I think that if you
launched a patreon that it would be
incredibly profitable for you at this
point I don't know if you know what's
going on on patreon with with folks who
have very controversial views on the
issues of the day but I don't know if
you're considering sort of a Jordan
Peterson type independent commentary for
a or something like that
maybe I really trying to figure out what
it is I like to do because I'm really
not the type of person that just wants
to broadcast my thoughts yeah you know I
only got Twitter right after this to you
know just share some of my interviews
and stuff yeah
but I'm not the type of person that you
know hosts a radio show I'm I'm much
more introverted in I just like reading
and solving problems gotcha
how long do you think the interviews
will continue like how long will certain
a certain point will you say listen I've
spoken about what happened I've sort of
said everything I have to say and this
is it for the public
James d'amour sort of
discussions yeah I'm not sure I've been
invited to multiple private speaking
engagements for example you know even
conferences on diversity and inclusion
they wanted to get my perspective well
and so you know I plan to at least share
my my views on other and other venues as
long as they'll carry me out and we
spark an interesting conversation last
thing I want to talk about if you could
speak now to someone who is at a company
that has a diversity policy like
Google's and they may be like you are
questioning some elements of it knowing
what you know now everything that's
happened and you said you do have some
regret about the way it's all gone down
would you encourage them to speak out
and risk what has happened to you or
would you say keep your head down
maybe just quietly find a different job
what would your advice be to others I
would maybe advise them to just talk to
the people working on it because you
know people want to do what's right and
some people just they don't know that
things aren't totally socially
constructed and they're basing their
assumptions based on that so yeah I
think just having a rational
conversation and trying to solve it one
on one rather than have maybe a fear of
doing gold I don't know yeah I mean I
knew you said in your other segment on
this that I shared it with 50,000 people
that's really not true I mean it became
shared with 50,000 people is sort of
more accurate right yeah it's just the
default Google Docs setting to be public
yeah we available within the company and
so people have found the link we're able
to access it sure sure all right well
we're going to continue to follow what
ultimately happens James I really do
appreciate you know that you reached out
to me that you wanted to be on the
program and and talked about this I
think that there's a lot of stuff here
that is not talked about as much as it
should be that doesn't mean you and I
would come to the same conclusions but I
do think that these are all really
important issues
and I've criticized both the left and
right on issues of speech and what it is
okay to talk about and even if our
conclusions are different I do
appreciate you coming on and for
everybody people were asking me has
James told you what you can and cannot
talk about we we barely we exchanged two
emails basically and you impose no
restrictions whatsoever and and we had
the conversation that I planned and I I
thank you for being on with me today
yeah thanks a lot